una ola migratoria haitiana se desplaza
por todo el continente americano en
colombia a cerca de unos 19 mil
ciudadanos esperan en la frontera con
panamá desde donde anhelan seguir su
camino hacia estados unidos o méxico
destino final de muchos tras las
deportaciones masivas de los últimos
días
la mayoría provienen de países del sur
como chile y brasil donde emigraron años
atrás en la frontera con el darién
enfrentan una de las partes más
peligrosas del camino hacia el norte
otro que queremos es que no deben pasar
antes antes que nos cierren la frontera
allá de lo está unido no va como que
dice quitar los sueños
pero
la situación de los que se encuentran en
mexico no es mucho mejor en ciudad acuña
cerca de la frontera con texas dos
docenas de personas fueron detenidas
para ser procesadas tras una redada
migratoria en un hotel muchos
retrocedieron desde estados unidos hacia
méxico escapando de la deportación y las
las condiciones si me sienta
decepcionado que nosotros pensamos allá
no es eso que quería a morelia son son
muy malo para nosotros si fuera que
nosotros somos basura no darle comida
agua nada nada no obstante miles de
haitianos siguen en el campamento de del
río eeuu hasta el momento el gobierno
del progresista joe biden ya ha
deportado a cientos de personas del país